So this is sort of a quick bookend to our
Iran story.
It appears that Eric Trump, Donald Trump's
son knew in advance about the assassination
that was carried out illegally without congressional
approval of the Iranian codes leader.
Kasseem Solemani of course, the assassination
took place on January 2nd, 2020 but just a
couple of days prior in the last 12 hours.
Really the last eight, nine hours of 2019
on December 31st Eric Trump tweeted, quote
bout to open up a big old can of whoop ass
hashtag don't mess with the best hashtag USA
USA USA.
This is believed now in retrospect to be a
clear reference to knowledge that Eric Trump
had of the upcoming unauthorized assassination
by the Trump administration of Iranian codes
leader Kaseem Soleimani.
Now, Eric Trump, since this came to light,
that wait a second, a whole bunch of people
who should have been briefed weren't briefed.
How did Eric Trump know about this?
Eric Trump has since deleted the tweet because
it became clear that Donald Trump did not
seek congressional authorization.
The assassination is likely illegal.
Congress didn't know and it seems that Donald
Trump's son, unelected, not a government employee,
doesn't have the clearance to know about this.
It seems that Eric Trump knew about this in
advance.
Here's a quote from Heather Cox Richardson,
a historian who's been covering this who said
quote, apparently the gang of eight was not
briefed.
Senate minority leader Chuck Schumer was not
told, although McConnell's spokesman refused
to comment on whether or not he meaning McConnell
was briefed and she goes on to say, Eric Trump,
who holds no security clearance, might've
been briefed on December 31st he tweeted about
to open up a big old can of whoop ass.
The tweet has now been deleted.
I will actually go even further now with the
2020 hindsight knowing what took place in
Iraq over the last 24 hours.
A couple of weeks ago, December 18th it was
reported that five top Pentagon officials
had resigned in a seven day period.
It was weird at the time, we didn't know,
you know, five top Pentagon officials resigning
in seven days doesn't really make sense.
The idea now that we are increasingly thinking
is the explanation for this is that the plan
was starting to develop at that point in time
in the second half, early in the second half
of December, these five key Pentagon officials
were against this completely immoral, arguably
illegal assassination and that they resigned.
Will we ever know the full truth of who knew
when and why they resigned?
And, and the, the lack of proper handling
of sensitive information here, probably not,
but this stinks to high heaven as usual.
It seems that Donald Trump is being totally
careless with his handling of sensitive information.
If indeed his son, Eric Trump, uh, knew in
advance about what was going on.
And then of course there is the political
side of Donald Trump for years saying, Hey,
Barack Obama, you need congressional approval.
The president can't do this.
The president can't strike there without congressional
approval.
Donald Trump letting Eric Trump know, but
not letting the gang of eight, no, not letting
congressional leadership know, not actually
going and seeking approval for doing this.
It's projection.
It's backwards.
It's all a tactic to try to get himself reelected.
In 20, and it really pains me to say it, but
it might work.
It might work if the last three years of observing
how Trump is to have been successfully propagandized
to and gas lit willingly to try to placate
their cognitive dissonance with Donald Trump.
If that's any indication, this may actually
work and we are increasingly driving towards
a war with Iran.
It was Hillary.
Remember it was Hillary that was going to
get us into Wars, into military conflicts
on authorized erratic bloodthirsty.
It seems like that was all projection.
Let me know what you think it is.
Uh, these are, these are scary and depressing
times.
Leave a comment.
If you're watching on YouTube or send me a
tweet on Twitter at D Pacman.
We'll take a break much to discuss on today's
program,